you want to talk about narcissism in our
culture there was a tick-tock video just
went viral from a woman named remy bader
and remy bader showed up to a ranch and
i guess she wanted to ride horses
but there was a problem
so she's walking around the ranch and
she's got a little caption there on her
tic toc video it says shout out to deep
hollow ranch and montauk for making me
leave
because i weigh
over 240 pounds
she's 240 there she is i don't think
they made her leave the grounds i don't
think they said you know you're gonna
fall through the earth and destroy the
crops because you're 240 pounds they
just wouldn't let her ride a horse and
she was really angry about that and she
took to tick-tock to complain about that
because it's all about her
you see the whole world is about her
and
the suffering of other creatures doesn't
matter as long as her pleasure is
satisfied
why do you think this woman was turned
away from riding the horses at the ranch
do you think it's because the ranchers
just hated her do you think it's because
of her terrible oppression or do you
think it's because she was gonna break
the back of the horse and they and they
took into consideration the feelings of
the horse as well and they took into
consideration propriety and what's good
and just outside of this woman's own
will
but she says i don't care if we break
the back of the horse what do i care
about the damn horse this is the same
thing that the marquis de sade said
truly the marquis decided from whom we
get the word sadism
his big question was
why is
your pain any more important than my
pleasure
that's
narcissism
that's the extreme
pathological version
of self-absorption and selfishness but
it's it's different it's much more than
just a regular old selfishness which
everybody's got it's this inability to
and unwillingness and
lack of desire to
take into account anyone or anything
else other than
oneself
this all she she can't even see how
ridiculous she looks posting that to
twitter
not just ridiculous because she's she's
bragging about her weight or says part
of the pop body positivity pride
movement
that that in itself is sort of a
ridiculous thing
but to come out and say can you believe
this they kicked me what about the poor
horse
oh you never thought about the horse
because you you guys
in this culture don't think about
anything other than yourself and it's
very
very sad for everybody involved
we are living in a really
low moment in our culture there's this
prejudice that modern people have that
we know so much more than all those
old-timey people you walk around the
ruins of ancient greece you think are
these idiots they didn't they didn't
even have iphones you know what a bunch
of dummies aristotle and plato what did
they know
they didn't even have computers
what what a bunch of dumb idiots they
had to walk around places but i have a
honda
those dummies they're they were so
unsophisticated and
so we have this idea that our culture is
really so much more advanced we're not
i think if you really look into
ancient rome at its height
you look into
athenian imperial
athenian democracy athenian imperial
democracy really you look at the great
civilizations you realize they really
had it a lot more together in many ways
than we do in some cases technologically
as well you look at the roman aqueducts
for goodness sakes
and i think the clearest example of this
today
is that while
the ancient athenians may not have had
iphones
they knew what a woman is
they knew
quite a lot about man and his role in
the universe
probably a lot more than the average
person in our culture knows today
we talk about this question what is a
woman this is a big daily wire
documentary
it's even gotten worse since then i
thought
that it could not possibly get dumber
than having to explain to large swaths
of our population that a man is not a
woman but actually it's gotten even
crazier we now have to explain to people
that elephants
are not people
this is a real court case
we're all waiting on the dobbs decision
from and other court decisions from from
the scotus today
i've got i've got an even crazier court
decision that just came out of the new
york state court of appeals
fortunately it was decided the right way
it was a 5-2 decision so actually
two judges on the court didn't seem to
understand that the case was about this
question are elephants people
this case was brought by the non-human
rights project this is a radical animal
rights group
the the organization requested a writ of
habeas corpus to take happy
a female asian elephant that was brought
to the bronx zoo in 1977 away from the
zoo
and the the reason they wanted this this
rid of habeas corpus this idea that you
have a right to your body
the group contended that happy the
elephant was not in fact an elephant but
a person
because they argued elephants possess
complex cognitive and emotional
capabilities and therefore because the
elephant
was practically speaking a person it was
illegal to confine the element elephant
to the zoo
i'm not denying that elephants
relative to other animals possess
high intelligence
sure
relative to human beings not even close
and a lot of people are confused about
this these days but relative to other
animals yeah elephants seem very
intelligent they possess an intellect
that is appropriate to their animal
condition
but they're not
people
this is a big
distinction here
we used to understand that
human beings are special
human beings uniquely possess will and
intellect
we have language such that we can
communicate not merely our appetites and
our desires but we can communicate in an
abstract and rational way about
objective reality to one another that's
how we're speaking right now that's how
you're hearing what i'm saying that's
how i'm going to hear from you in the
voicemail bag on friday that's how we
have self-government it's how we decide
what to have for dinner and everything
else in between
that is different from any other animal
including the elephants who are
relatively very intelligent that's true
but the elephants aren't people here's
how i'll prove it to you
if elephants are persons if they are
people
then when they kill
other elephants
when they certainly when they kill
people
we would put them on trial
right that's what happens when you're a
person when you do bad things when
you're a person when you commit crimes
you are held to account for those crimes
and you're given a trial and you have
the right to due process and then you
can be
you can make a defense for yourself or
you get a lawyer
and then you're found guilty or innocent
do you think we would we should have a
trial if an elephant kills some other
animal and eats it
no that would be ridiculous
do you think we should even have a trial
if an elephant
kills a human being there are throughout
history actually some really bizarro
cases of people who either as a kind of
public spectacle or because of a great
deal of confusion have tried to try
animals and then
hang them or execute them
the reason that these are notable
throughout history is because they're so
absurd we all know every single person
with two brain cells to rub together on
earth knows that it would be
preposterous to put an elephant on trial
why because we know that the elephant
isn't a person
human rights
such as they are
are inseparable from human
responsibilities human duties human
obligations and all of those things the
human rights and the obligations and the
duties are inseparable from humanity
which is different in kind from the rest
of the natural environment not just
different in degree
like the libs want us to believe
but different in kind we're actually
special we're actually made in the image
of god
and this isn't just some mystical pie in
the sky kind of notion this has real
practical consequences and real
practical effects that we can observe
the fact that we can reason in an
abstract way the fact that we have a
lower will the appetite and a higher
will and we can actually sort of tame
the appetite to some degree through the
rational will that mediates between the
divine will and the appetite all these
sorts of things i'm just giving you the
very
basic overview of the most elemental
aspects of philosophy that have been
discarded because we've replaced all of
that with with will we've replaced all
of that with just i want i want i want i
think the reason that the libs are
confusing animals with human beings is
not because the animals are behaving
like human beings it's because the human
beings are behaving like animals
and we're we're neglecting and
discarding our higher will and our
reason and our facts and our logic why
do you think that the videos ben kind of
first popularized them but then they
became a whole genre of the internet
so and so destroys such and such with
facts and logic why did that become such
a big phenomenon because we're living in
a culture that increasingly discards
facts and logic and we know that that's
special we know that facts and logic are
special and important and
and something that play a central role
in human life or at least they did until
recently and we missed that that's why
that's why we get all those clicks on
youtube folks
it's also why we're because that the
elephants no matter how advanced they
are
they cannot own you with facts and logic
they will own you with their trunks and
their hoofs and smush you if you cross
them i'm glad you like that clip now
ding ring wada wadda bing bong make sure
you hit that bell and subscribe
you will get all the notifications then
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe there too
to the michael knowles show leave a five
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you